الصينيه تلغي قيود السفر وتفتح ابوابها من
جديد لاستقبال النسخه الاسيويه من المؤتمر
العالمي للتقنيات النقاله ام دبليو سي
شونج هاي 2023 هيا بنا لنتعرف معا على
جديد نسخه هذا العام كل هنا يتحدث عن
الجيل المقبل من شبكات الاتصال اللاسلكيه
ما علاقه هذا الجيل بالجيل الحالي وقاطع
الفيديو ثلاثيه الابعاد المشهوره هذه
الايام تخيل لو كنت مؤثرا او كنت تقوم ببث
حي فبدلا من عمل فيديو تقليدي يمكنك تصوير
فيديو او عمله بث ثلاثي الابعاد استعرضت
شركته هواوي الصينيه ابرز منتجاتها من
الهواتف المحموله والساعات الذكيه هنا
مثلا احدث هواتفها القبيله للطايميت اكس 3
الذي قامت باعاده صياغته من جديد مقارنه
بالجيل السابق هذه المره مع شاشه قابله
للطيف الداخل يعد ميت اكس 3 احد اخف وانحف
الاجهزه القابله للطيف السوق حاليا ويتميز
الذي يمكن ضبطه في اي زاويه ياتي الهاتف
مقويما للمات ويدعم شحن سلكيا بقوه 66 وات
ولاسلكيا بقوه 50 وات وهو مزود بعدسه
مقربه يمكنها التقليب بصريا حتى 5 مرات
تزاحم الزوار في انتظار دورهم لتجربه
نظارات الواقع المعزز اللاسلكيه وهي اول
نظرات واقع معزز في العالم تدعم تقنيه
تشاجي بالذكاء الاصطناعي وتقوم بعرض
وانشاء النصوص امام عينيك مما يتيح
التفاعل الذكي مثل الكتابه الصوتيه
والدردشه بالاوامر الصوتيه والترجمه
الفوريه باستخدام نماذج ذكائن اصطناعي
كبيره
عادت شركه ميزو الصينيه التابعه لشركه
جيلي لصناعه السيارات الى مشهد الهواتف
الذكيه بسبيكراها العشرين ياتي ميزو 20
برو بشاشه اوليد بمقاسات فاصله ثمانيه
بمعدل تحديث 120 هرتز ثلاثه كاميرات خلفيه
عريضه فائقه الاتساع ومقربه توقفنا هذا
الابتك الصغير والعمليه لصناعه المحتوى
الخاص بالواقع الافتراضي والمختلط من شركه
كاندا والصينيه وهو كوكام ايجو يتكون هذا
الجهاز من قطعتين تلتصقان مع بعضهما البعض
مغناطيسيا كما نشاهد بفصل القطاعتين نحصل
هنا على كاميرا
بعدستين هنا تلتقطان صورا وفيديوهات
ثلاثيه الابعاد بدقه اما بالنسبه للسعر
فيبلغ حوالي 1700 يوان صيني اي ما يعادل
250 دولار